i think that the way that we currently
do education is is wrong and and
we're when you see something like the
khan academy and so forth that's
probably going in the right direction i
mean generally you want education to be
like as close to a video game as
possible like a good video game like you
do not need to tell your kid to
play video games they will play video
games on autopilot all day
so
if you can make it interactive and
engaging
uh then then you can make education
far more compelling and far easier to do
so
i think that's how it should be and it
shouldn't be that you've got like these
grades where people move in lockstep um
and so everyone
goes through you know goes like normally
you know we'll go through
english math
uh
science and so forth from like fifth
grade to sixth grade to seventh grade
like it's an assembly line
but but people are not objects on an
assembly line that's a ridiculous notion
people learn and are interested in
different things at different paces
so you really want to
disconnect the whole grade level three
thing from the subjects allow people to
progress at the fastest pace that they
can or are interested in in each subject
want to be happy build a life not just a
business
hey it's evan carmichael and this
channel was created to help you overcome
the number one challenge that is holding
you back a lack of belief in yourself
you watch these videos because you know
there's something more inside you two
you've got michael jordan level genius
at something so today let's live your
best believe life and get seven amazing
lessons from elon musk bill gates and
other billionaire entrepreneurs enjoy
lesson number two tap into your
spirituality with oprah winfrey are you
ready to allow abundance and blessings
people can't figure out how i got to be
so successful it is because i have lived
in the space of spirit my whole life my
favorite
bible verse because i am christian uh is
acts
something i used to note a number but
this is an axe y'all can google it
but it says
thank you 1728
in god i live and move and have my being
i live and move and have my being and
you want to know why i am really so
successful i knew that at four years old
i knew that when my grandmother said you
better watch me now because one day you
have to learn how to wash these clothes
and hang them up like this so watch how
i hold these clothes pins in my mouth
[Applause]
and the reason i could do that is
because spirit
otherwise known as intuition
my instinct said
that's not gonna be my life
so we all have that spiritual side and
this lesson tonight is about connecting
to it i believe that beneath the surface
of all physical problems is a spiritual
solution there is a spiritual solution
why because you are a spiritual being
having a human experience that's the
beginning of understanding spirituality
you are a spiritual being
having a human
experience lesson number three
attract investors with jeff bezos there
are a few things i think
uh if you want to be a innovative
company that you you have to do
first of all
i think innovation is a point of view
you have to actually select people that
are part of the company who want to
innovate and explore
being a pioneering
company
an explorer company
isn't for everybody some people wake up
in the morning and they get their
uh
energy the thing they think about in the
shower is they start their annual
planning process or however you want to
think about it with who are the three
companies that we're going to kill this
year
that's the conqueror mentality
and it's a competitor-focused mentality
instead of a customer-focused mentality
and there's nothing
that that mentality can succeed by the
way so i'm not claiming you know the
pioneering explorer approach is the only
effective one
but when you've when you attract people
who have the dna of pioneers and the dna
of explorers you build a company of
like-minded people who want to invent
and that's what they think about when
they get up in the morning how are we
going to work backwards from customers
and build a great service or a great
product
you you you that's uh that's a key
element in to invention okay and that
part is fun by the way so if you're the
right kind of person and you like to
invent you like change
uh
and you see everything you see as you
move about the world you think how it
could be improved that's just fun and we
at amazon we've over the last 18 plus
years attracted a bunch of people like
that and we have a ton of fun doing it
lesson number four pay to play with
grant cardone what's your biggest tip
for anyone who
you know they obviously have all
intention purposes to to want to
collaborate what are some of the
the the best ins or the best ways around
money money of course pay money pay to
play money works yeah pay to play yep
universal language planet earth pay to
play
you know
whatever people i was doing before our
last conference and maybe we wrapping up
with this before our last conference a
guy came in my office from a big bank
and said hey i want to uh i want to talk
to you about lending you some money for
multi for your apartment building so i'm
like great
have you bought a ticket to my
conference
no i haven't i said i don't have time
for you
so it's like pay to play man it is the
simplest hack on planet earth i'm going
to take garbage pieces of paper
dumb little pieces of rectangle paper
and give them to you to speed up my
process i don't know why i don't know
why i didn't know this for 45 years yeah
and and i don't know why i was so hung
up
on trading paper for access
it's what all the big players do yeah i
mean i even had this arrogant thing i'm
not paying i'm not paying to connect up
like dude this is how everything works
on this planet hey man
how you doing buddy good how are you you
got a book coming out don't you
uh you just came out
where can people get it
get it on amazon easiest spot built to
serve right there
let's go man if you guys don't know evan
follow evan carmichael he's got a new
book out build a serve go grab it today
at amazon
there's a good dude right here lesson
number five value feedback with bill
gates every software project is a glass
half full in terms of things that
went super well and things that didn't
go super well and
you know the great thing about software
is
particularly if your software is popular
you hear back from users they tell you
what they like what they don't like you
know maybe there's a device driver
missing maybe the error message isn't
perfectly clear
on exactly what you're supposed to do
you hear about it and it's great because
that creates that that feedback loop
lesson number six do what you love with
mark cuban i get that question all the
time so what industry should i look at i
can tell i can tell you all about
artificial intelligence computer vision
personalized medicine
but then what right
and so the and maybe you you're an
expert in one of those fields and you
can go for it but what i tend to try to
tell people in terms of what does it
take to be successful
find something you love to do and then
be great at it
not average
not marginal not good enough
but if you can be great at it be great
at it if you are the the greatest
videographer
in the history of videographers
people don't care about cell phones
what is it that
you can do
that makes them know that what you the
way you do it is special
and if you can do that and convey it
then you'll be fine if you're not sure
then
you know
you've got you've got to decide whether
you want to stay on your own get it you
know be a contractor or go work for
somebody you know it just depends you
know and let me add one other thing
i i crushed myself
um
and like my brothers didn't they they
took a completely different path and
they were looking just nine to five at
yada yada not everybody's got to be an
entrepreneur and so if you if you've got
it in your blood and that's what you
want to do then find a way to be great
and if not you know you'll figure it out
you'll find something else and lesson
number seven the last one before some
very special bonus clips is believe with
jamie kern lima i also knew that like of
course i'd have to work really really
hard if i was ever gonna make it of
course i'd have to get back up every
time i got knocked down on the journey
but i knew if i was gonna make it like
the most important thing came down to me
believing that i could
and for me
you know
and here's the thing a lot of times we
hold ourselves back because we say
things to ourselves like oh i'm not
qualified or oh i feel this like dream
on my heart to whatever it is launch a
podcast whatever it is but it's like oh
but i'm you know don't know how and i
don't know i have no connections and all
the things we tell ourselves and
for me
in a way it almost made no sense that i
created a beauty company right and
just the idea of it because i didn't
know anything about it i knew no one in
the industry but every time i get still
like for me um and you know no matter
what people believe whether it's they're
hearing the universe talk to them or god
talk to them like for me i hear it
through my own intuition now i've got a
special bonus clip that i think you're
going to enjoy but before that it's time
for the question of the day i want to
know what was your single biggest
takeaway from this video and your plan
of action for the next week when you
watch a video and just get motivated you
have a 35 chance of actually following
through that's what the science says and
that is not good enough believe nation
we need to do better when you actually
get motivated and then create a specific
plan of action for what you're going to
do this week you have a 91 chance of
following through and when you publicly
commit to somebody else like leaving a
comment below on this video it jumps
even higher so i want that for you i
want to know your single biggest
takeaway from this video and your plan
of action for the next week so i can
celebrate with you
during my california springs and summers
i spent most of my days in the high
sierras in yosemite valley working
as a river guide
and a rock climbing instructor
i loved those jobs
but unfortunately they didn't pay that
well
so i also got a job working a couple of
days a week as a computer programmer
back in berkeley
i had learned a program in college
i didn't love programming
but it was fun and i was good at it and
computer program programming gave me the
same kind of satisfaction
as solving math problems and playing
chess
both things i enjoyed before before i
became a confused
teenager at this point in my life
i thought i was making real progress on
my journey of self-discovery
i had found a cause
i had a couple of jobs that i loved
and one that was fun and paid the bills
i was pretty happy with my life
my wife was not
what she saw was a college dropout who
spent too much time in the mountains
doing foolish things
she wanted me to work full time as a
computer programmer or go back to
college and finish my degree
we compromised
sort of
i started taking classes at uc berkeley
i took several classes but the only one
i can remember was a sailing class
taught at berkeley marina
once again i fell in love and began a
lifelong affair
with the limitless omnipotent pacific
ocean
when my class was over i wanted to buy a
sailboat
my wife said
this was the single stupidest idea she
had ever heard in her entire life
she accused me of being irresponsible
and she told me i lacked ambition
she kicked me out
and then she divorced me
[Music]
this was a pivotal moment in my life
[Applause]
my family was still mad at me for not
going to medical school
and now my wife was divorcing me because
i lacked ambition
it looked like a reoccurrence of the
same old problem
once again i was unable to live up to
the expectations of others
but this time
i was not disappointed in myself
for failing to be
the person they thought i should be
their dreams
and my dreams were different
i would never confuse the two of them
again the key thing
was that paul allen and i
had loved working on software since we
were lucky enough to be exposed
literally i was 13 and 8th grade when
this time sharing terminal came in and
we just did it day and night and you
know got better and we could see
that the magic of software combined with
this miracle of the microprocessor
subject to moore's law exponential
improvement that that was a magic
combination and we we'd look around and
say hey how come everybody's not
saying this is amazing i mean we're
gonna dethrone ibm and uh you know why
doesn't digital equipment get it why is
the guy who runs it this is a company
that's long gone uh but dominated many
computers at the time why isn't that guy
up there saying it's it's wrong we know
it's right
and so the key event for us was it was a
very cold boston winter
and a kid computer came out on uh this
popular electronics magazine
and we said oh
this is happening without us i mean here
we are
uh
doing nothing
and so we called the company up and said
you know hey we're ready uh and then we
called them back we actually did the
work and then we called them back and
said how do you make the stuff go in and
out of the computer the i o
and they said well that's interesting
nobody else has ever asked that you must
really be doing something so that was
anyway our very first customer and so we
grabbed on to it to be the very first
and we were the first to say there
should be a software industry and come
and do it in a sense it was one of the
lower risk things i've ever done in my
life because
you know i could have always gone back
we go back to when i started my
partnership in 1956 that berkshire came
out of there were seven people sitting
there at a table
having dinner
relatives primarily and i said here's
the partnership agreement
it's done under nebraska law it's four
or five pages you don't need to read it
but i said here's a little
half page what i call the ground rules
and i want you to read these
and if you feel okay about that
about the interaction what the
expectations are and all of that sort of
thing then we'll join forces and if you
don't it's fine other people have you
know but we don't we shouldn't be
partners i mean you know if i'm going to
have a partnership with somebody i want
to be compatible it is you know and
when you have a
public company you can't control who
comes in i can't control some guy that
comes in and thinks we're gonna pay big
dividends or split the stock or
something like that so by my actions
and my communications and everything i
want to attract the people
that
from the public market that i want and i
want to keep the others away costco was
built
sal price who started the price club
that thing
he sat down and figured out the customer
he didn't want and he set up a system
that would keep away the customer didn't
want who did not want he didn't want
somebody buying a quart of milk with
somebody behind them with a with a
basket of 200 worth of goods waiting for
that so we put in a membership fee and
by putting in a membership page he
killed all the drop in business the
business to belong to the 7-eleven
we want berkshire
to to keep out people who have
expectations about us that are different
than ours i mean good for them and i
hope they find somebody they said but
if you're going to run a church
you want you want your seats to be
filled by people that are generally want
to listen to your form of religion and
you don't want to change every week and
say gee i need a new group and i'll go
out and talk to a bunch of investors and
get them to come to my church this
sunday because there's only so many
seats in the church there's a million
645 000 or so a equivalent shares and
those are the seats and i want them
occupied by people that are on the same
page i am we felt a little bad i i
certainly i did about leaving the
university
when
uh i thought very interesting work on
artificial intelligence was really on
the verge of taking place and
symbolically proving programs were
correct ironically now you know it's
taken a long time the rate of progress
which is hard to make numeric in both
those areas has been quite modest i mean
we haven't gone backwards or anything
but ai
has turned out to be a tougher problem
which is is fascinating and now there
there are some interesting advances and
likewise symbolic
type things there are some now advances
so we thought we'd miss
uh being more at the center of those now
through at least funding microsoft
research we get to have some
level of involvement in that
one of paul's ideas was to build a 360
emulator that was the dominant mainframe
of the time use bit slice
architecture to just you know blow away
the pricing on
mainframe computing but we decided that
was kind of boring uh compared to
personal computing a company came along
about five years later to pi and did it
uh they didn't do the software piece
right that's why they failed uh because
we still think it was a good idea but we
didn't have anything even close to hey
let's build a computer that we want to
use that we want to have as a tool for
our own
uh messing around and communication and
creativity that
that kind of got at the center of our
thinking even from the
early days
of business
yes
is
everyone thinks that spanx actually
started when i cut the feet out of my
pantyhose but the truth is it started
many many years before that it started
when i was selling fax machines
door-to-door
getting kicked out of office buildings
day in and day out and i woke up one
morning and i thought
i'm in the wrong movie
how did this happen this is not my life
cut scene call the director call the
producer no and i took out a piece of
paper and i wrote down what i was good
at
and there was not much on the page
the word i saw the word sales i knew i
was good in sales so i wrote down in my
journal
i want to invent a product that i can
sell to millions of people
that will make them feel good
and then i asked the universe for an
idea
and i waited for two years
and the idea showed up
and the minute i cut the feet out of my
pantyhose i decided to pursue it
so
what do you do when you have an idea and
you've never taken a business class or
worked in fashion or retail
i wanted to patent my idea
and i ended up
looking for a female patent attorney and
i called the georgia chamber of commerce
and they said there actually wasn't a
single female patent attorney in the
entire state of georgia
so i looked in the yellow pages and
found three men's name and went out and
pitched my idea to them and they
actually thought the idea was so bad
that one of the patent lawyers later
admitted to me he thought i'd been sent
by candid camera
which makes sense because he was looking
around the room for the hidden cameras
but he ended up eventually helping me i
went to barnes noble bought a book on
patents and trademarks wrote my own
patent
and went back to him and said please
please will you just write the claims
portion of it and he did for a
discounted price
but it makes me think about inventors
and innovators and when you hear those
words do you think of women
last year my son
had inventor week at his school and they
asked me to come and be the keynote
speaker at his kindergarten class
so
i was the inventor that was coming and i
started out looking at all these cute
little kids and i said so what does an
inventor look like
and all their hands shot up and one kid
said it's a man and he has crazy hair
and somebody else raised her in and said
no no no it's a bald man
no it's a tall man it's a short man and
i just stopped and i said
well i'm an inventor
and their eyes got really big and they
said you are
and it dawned on me i looked around the
room and all the pictures of inventors
were albert einstein thomas edison steve
jobs so i can see why the the young girl
who asked me and said i didn't know
girls could be inventors was surprised
and even my son on the way home he goes
mom you're an inventor
but the real point of all of this was i
wanted to help women and i'm so
passionate about it and it's amazing
that i started with their butts and i've
continued to groan i started at the
sarah blakely foundation because i truly
believe that the world would be a much
better place if the male and female
energy on the planet was more balanced
do you remember how much your first
server cost you said oh yeah no
eighty-five dollars eighty-five dollars
yeah no i i remember that because um
that was the gating factor for us
launching new schools i i mean we had
this philosophy from the very beginning
that we didn't wanna be this project it
wasn't even a company at the very
beginning but we didn't want to be
burning a lot of money right we weren't
planning on raising a lot of money we
didn't want to be one of these things
that raised a bunch of money and you
know was losing a bunch of money and
then decided that we'd somehow pull it
through at the end and
um so you know so
85 for the first server put ads on the
site and the the ads at the beginning
were uh we just were running some kind
of ad network and you remember what the
first ad was
um
no i don't um
i don't know how did you get ads um this
was eduardo's job
was i mean with your ad sales yeah he
basically like he was responsible for
making sure that we had enough money to
keep things running in the beginning and
um
you know but basically i mean so it was
the server was 85
and you know dustin and i basically
worked on kind of efficiency and making
sure that we can fit more schools onto
each server um and um and eduardo worked
on selling more ads or making a deal so
that we can get an ad network so that
way we can we can make more money but
then whenever we had more money we
rented another 85 a month server and we
kind of went from there and um i don't
know just it's just an interesting way
of seeing you never spent money you
didn't have in the beginning not in the
beginning no and then i mean even that
was the constraint on your growth rate
how many new 85 dollars as you could get
yeah and i mean it was actually good
because i i mean you know sometimes it's
really nice to have the time to
get your product to be awesome and deal
with scaling problems and one of the
things that was interesting was um
you know at the time i don't know how
many people remember this but i mean
friendster was the service that had
massive scaling problems yeah you know
the idea was they were they grew quickly
and it was really hard for them to scale
and um you know the fact that we could
kind of go college by college and and
kind of optimize the service and make it
more efficient and offer new features
but make sure that they worked um i
think was really key i mean we're
talking about people who had never built
a company before we never built any
large scale software
or anything so having that period where
we could just bake it
and you know people these days like to
talk about how these services grow super
quickly and facebook did grow quickly
but i think it took a year for us to get
a million users and we thought that that
was incredibly fast i decided to to
focus more on
uh giving away than than making money
and so i've
gotten a chance to travel the world be
out in africa and asia quite a bit and
see the needs that are out there and now
our foundation is very focused on global
health uh focused on agriculture because
the majority of the the very poor in the
world are farmers who have very small
plots of land so any increase in
productivity or certainty of their crop
coming in
can make huge difference for them
and you might think of a career in
software
you know selling to uh people who can
afford personal computers and now
uh the career at the foundation is being
very different and certainly they're
different in the sense that now it's
about vaccines now a lot it's it's with
various uh governments uh the donor
governments the governments and import
countries but at its core it's really
basically the same thing which is
uh finding innovators uh people who've
got breakthrough ideas
be willing to back them understand what
they're working on
measure
what they're coming up with
try and make sure that when it's
delivered it really has the impact it's
supposed to be and getting into a
feedback loop driven by
a very precise measurement two weeks ago
i went i went uh plant only
plant-based plant-based i was afraid i
dropped the meat dude that's so i want
to do i did that for a week last week
yeah and i felt amazing i had a lot more
gas just from all the plants i think but
it's cleaning it out
that's not too much information for me
but i've had uh way more energy yeah but
like and less inflammation and less pain
yeah i hadn't noticed i have a little
bit of inflammation in in my hands but
that hadn't hadn't changed but
the plant-based thing i watched the game
the the game changing show yeah
and uh when he said
dude you're eating the middleman
like when i heard that that was enough
for me right eating the middleman you're
eating the middleman
meaning the cow the cow eats the grass
right you go right
the source is the grass yeah and as soon
as i heard that i'm like what the [ __ ]
am i doing eating the middleman
i ain't a middleman guy i want to go
directly to the source
where all the energy's at yeah i mean
like like
that was the line in the show that did
me wow and i've been thinking about it
too i've eaten meat for 60 years i grew
up on bacon
four pieces of bacon every day so good
uh oh yeah totally
the eggs i i have not eaten any meat
in 12 days
and my energy is freaking
this all day long oh wow
3 30 in the afternoon for the last 25
years i crash at 3 30. hard crash i mean
like
i'll see you guys uh call me later okay
what you doing at 3 30. i got i got a
meeting yeah and that meeting was on
that nap dude and when i hit it i'm
talking coma
[Laughter]
deep sleep
better than
sleep at night sometimes it would be 30
minutes sometimes it'd be an hour and a
half
like comatose 12 days i'm i can't take a
nap
i try to go take a nap i cannot fall
asleep
so i'll get my energy do you think
you're gonna stick with this do you
think you'll have meat sometimes do you
think i mean i'm not i'm not like i'm
not a fanatic guy so yeah so it's a
little meat here and there or something
i'm just gonna eat what makes me feel
best yeah so
i don't care if it was meat if it was
pork it was bacon but right now
um
as long as i can find the greens
and i haven't i haven't missed the meat
i like to putter in the morning i get up
early i go to bed early i get up early i
like to putter in the mornings i like to
read the newspaper i like to have coffee
i like to have
breakfast with my kids before they go to
school so i have my
kind of puttering time is very important
to me and so that's why i set my first
meeting for 10 o'clock
i like to do my high iq meetings
before lunch like anything that's going
to be really mentally challenging that's
a 10 o'clock meeting and because by 5
p.m i'm like
i can't think about that today let's try
this again tomorrow at 10 a.m
and um and so then on sleep i get eight
hours of sleep i prioritize it unless
i'm traveling in different time zones
sometimes it's impossible but
i am very um focused on it and and and
for me i need adults to sleep i think
better i have more energy my mood is
better all these things 2008 in
particular was was was awful because um
we had the third launch failure in a row
of
of our falcon vehicle at spacex um
and um
we uh
the tesla financing round that we were
raising fell apart
because the economy was going to
tailspin
um and it's pretty hard to raise money
for a startup car company uh you know
late 2008 when gm and chrysler are busy
going bankrupt
um that that was that was tough and then
solar city had a deal with uh morgan
stanley and morgan stanley had to renege
on the deal because they themselves were
running out of money um so it looked
like all three companies were gonna die
and i was also going through divorce so
that was definitely a low point so it's
2008 you're going through a divorce
which like some to borrow your word
douchebag vloggers are writing about to
make even worse right oh yes that's true
um in addition to
all that stuff happening i was getting
dumped on massively in the press right
yeah you're you know it looks like all
three companies yeah are gonna file i
mean
why do you keep going with all three
like i feel like even a lot of great
entrepreneurs in that situation would
have been like i've already sunk
everything i have in these companies
and i got to pick one
but you didn't i mean you kept doing all
three why um yeah that was a that was a
very tough call
um
at the end of 2008 that was that was
probably the tough you know one of the
toughest goals i've had to make
because i could either
um
reserve capital for one company or the
other i mean before solo city didn't
need a ton of capital so they were okay
but between spacex and and and tesla
um
you know it's sort of like like you've
got two kids
and
what do you do do you spend all your
money to to maximize probably the
success of one or do you
try to keep both light unfortunately it
worked it's very important to to seek
out
to actively seek out um and listen very
carefully to negative feedback
um
and this is something that people tend
to avoid because it's it's painful yeah
um
but
but i think this is a very common
mistake is to to not actively seek out
and listen to
uh negative feedback what do you do that
you go into forums do you go into
twitter like what are your areas where
you go to look for feedback on let's say
the tesla
well it's like everyone i talk to is um
in fact when um when friends get a
product i say look
don't tell me what you like tell me what
you don't like right um and and because
otherwise your friend is not going to
tell you what he doesn't like right the
skill is going to say oh i love this and
that and and then and leave out the this
is the stuff i don't like list because
too much of your friend want you know it
doesn't want to offend you so um
so you really need to
[Music]
to to to sort of coax negative feedback
um
and you should you know that if somebody
is your is your friend or at least not
your enemy and they're giving you
negative feedback
um then
they may be wrong but it's coming from a
good place
um and sometimes even your enemies give
you good negative feedback when i
started the first internet companies up
to um
with my brother and another person um a
great curry the
uh it wasn't really with the thought of
being wealthy
you know we're going against being
wealthy but
um
we'll get back to that later
but it's just it was just from the
standpoint i've been wanting to be part
of the internet and uh
i i figured if we could make enough
money to just get by would be that'll be
okay
um and when we started off uh we we
literally only had like one computer and
so it would be our web server during the
day and i'd code at night
and we we just got a
a small office um
in palo alto back when rent was not
insane
and
it cost us like 450 a month it was
cheaper than an apartment so we actually
just slept in the office and then [ __ ]
and then showered at the ymca at page
mill el camino so we'd walk over there
and shower and uh
and that was um actually i think uh
that was when i we first i first met you
by the way um and uh
so i don't know how many people probably
not many people know this but uh
uh we actually pitched uh steve in like
january 96
on
the zip2 business plan
and actually i thought
she was
actually one of the most up to speed on
on what actually was in our business
plan most most people we met did not
actually read our business plan um in
fact a lot of people a lot of venture
capitalists we met at the time didn't
even know what the internet was or
they've never used they'd never used
the things we still do
yeah i'm sorry like you know sort of
well-known people in san diego i was
like wow okay
but at the time nobody made any any
money on the internet so i guess that's
um
you know
it wasn't really clear evidence that
there was was a business today oracle
employs around 150 000 people
but when i started
it was not my intention
to build a big company
what happened
well at first we did exactly what we set
out to do
hired the most talented software
engineers in silicon valley
we assembled an all-star team of gifted
programmers
who were among the best in the world at
what they did
that team
plus one crazy idea
gave birth to a giant company
i call it a crazy idea
because at the time
everyone told me it was a crazy idea
the idea was to build the world's first
relational database
several theoretical papers about
relational databases had already been
published and ibm was building a
prototype in their research labs
but back then the collective wisdom of
computer experts
was that
while relational databases could be
built
they would never be fast enough to be
useful
i thought all those so-called computer
experts
were wrong
and when you start telling people
that all the experts are wrong
at first they call you arrogant
and then they say you're crazy
so remember this graduates
when people start telling you
that you're crazy you just might be on
to the most important innovation in your
life i was out on the road and i think a
lot of entrepreneurs make the mistake
they think once you get the order you're
golden and that couldn't be any farther
from the truth once you get the order
that's when the real work starts i was
absolutely determined to ensure my own
success and i think that's what it takes
i didn't want my success to be
contingent on anyone else having to sell
this so i hit the ground running and i
went from department store to department
store and i would do morning rallies at
the store where i would gather people
around well the store manager said sarah
you know you can do it with the hosiery
associates well i'd travel all the way
to arizona and there'd be three hosiery
associates so i quickly was like i gotta
get the whole store at this morning
rally so i would go into the entrance
before the store opened like a neiman's
or a saks or a bloomingdale's and i
would run around and introduce myself to
every employee setting up their station
i'd say hi i'm sarah and i would try to
convince them that it would be worth
their time to come see my morning
meeting and i got everybody there i had
taken the oprah clip and the a little
bit of local press i'd i'd received and
put it on a video and
did that in my morning rally
and
it was such an important thing that i
was doing i inadvertently was building a
sales force that wasn't on my payroll
and they all across the country became
my biggest advocates for the product and
started selling it on behalf of spanx
and me do you think there's a proven
formula that if a brand rookie guy he's
got a lot of ambitious gun out of this
but not a lot of knowledge and how to do
you think if he follows a formula he's
guaranteed to make it as an entrepreneur
no no no okay so you don't believe
there's a guarantee to make it no
because who knows who you're going to be
competing with so if you put two two
people both following the same formula
both in the same industry right which
one wins you know maybe they both can
win and both be successful but you know
so i don't i don't think there's a
default default template for success but
i think there's things that you can do
to put yourself in the best position to
succeed you know so i talk about stuff
in the book you know i talk about the
one thing in business you can control
his effort
you know um going out there and sales
curing all you know so i i think you
know and i agree with your point that
there are things that if you do them you
put yourself in the best position to
succeed
but you know if you just walk into a
buzz you know a buzzsaw and somebody
else is doing them a little bit better
you know what happens one of the
precursors one of the foundational
things
to being able to take risk is to have
had some kind of support from somebody
you have to have some mentors
you have to have somebody who loves you
these are the kind of things that build
up and allow you
to kind of you know jump off into
uncharted terrain and do something new
because you know you have
a support system of one kind or another
and uh and i certainly did so
for me i just want to point out that i i
i feel very strongly that
um
there's a lot i've won a lot of
lotteries uh amazon is one of the
lotteries that i've won but i had a big
lottery with my parents my dad is a
cuban immigrant he came here when he was
16 years old didn't speak any english
uh my
his is a great guy
and my uh mother
had her uh had me when she was 17 years
old so she was a pregnant 16 year old in
albuquerque new mexico in high school
which was not cool
and uh
she made it work and her her parents my
grandparents helped her with that whole
thing and made made that all work and if
you don't get that kind of support
somehow it doesn't have to be your
parents sometimes people get lucky it's
a grandparent or it's a friend or a
family friend or a teacher it can be
somebody but you need that somebody has
to step into your life and that's a
lottery that i suspect a lot of people
in this room have also won just like me
i have constructed a business that fits
me
it's kind of crazy to spend your life
painting if you're painting a subject
you don't want to look at
i've gotten to paint my own painting in
business
on an unlimited canvas in a way
it's a different sort of place
i work with great group of people that
make my life very easy and take good
care of me
we have 25 people in the office and if
you go back it's the exact same 25 the
exact same ones
we don't have any committees at
berkshire
we don't have a public relations
department we don't investor relations
we don't have a general counsel we don't
have a human relations department we
just don't go for anything that people
do just as a matter of form
it's exactly the life i like we have a
culture that's very focused on
being very focused on what we're
building so focus is a really important
part of it but it wasn't at google for a
long time now it seems to be in vogue so
they may be saying you know this the
focus is better so
but at the same time we want to make
sure that everyone can come and and add
their ideas i mean some of the best
ideas throughout the the company's
evolution
they have just been from just places all
throughout the company whether it's an
engineer or you know someone on the the
customer support team or just different
uh just different areas around the
company so
we've always had these hackathons right
that are basically time that we allocate
that the only rules that you don't work
on what you work on the rest of the time
and it's basically an incubator for
people to prototype different ideas much
in the spirit of how facebook got
founded originally um the idea that you
can build anything good in a day or a
couple of days right and get a version
of that running um so you get it running
you then test it internally yeah and
then we can see and that helps us shape
the roadmap and what we want to do in
the future but we also have a culture
where we want to stay very focused and
we don't want to run with a lot of
projects that we don't expect to launch
right so
so we want to get a lot of ideas help
have those ideas shape where we want to
go and then execute in a very focused
way on the stuff that we're going to do
but i mean
our culture i mean we have a few values
that are really important to us and one
which i talked about before is just
moving fast right the whole company is
really optimized around someone joining
being able to
build something very quickly be able to
launch it quickly
iterate very quickly on that everybody
can be successful
if you really try try hard
i started alibaba 1999 in my apartment
i talked to the 18 founders
that one thing one of the things we want
to prove
if jack ma and his team can be
successful 80 percent of the people in
the world they can be successful
because we don't have money we have
technology we don't have almost nothing
the only thing is that we believe in the
future
and start to do
little by little it does not matter
who you know
it matters who knows you
so i'm going to go up i'm going to go
i'm trying to get to feed you right
okay look i mean i could know some i
could know some people that own places
in fiji but what if it's already booked
they can't kick them out
but what if people in fiji knew i was
coming they're like hey mr cardone i
want them calling me i don't want to
call them
and so who knows you we're back to the
question of who's got my money who's got
your money is who knows you people do
business with people they know
it's how business has been done for two
thousand years in this plan not people
don't do business with people they trust
they do but they first do business with
people they know
i gotta know you before i trust you
and i would rather do business with
somebody i know
and don't trust i do business with
people every day i don't trust
every day
i have to don't you think there's
there's an element of so for example but
i know that wouldn't get this deal i
know they can get the deal done with me
right like the real estate broker i know
i'm not getting quite the truth from him
on this or that but you know what he's
got the deal i just did two deals i did
a hundred and twenty million dollars
real estate deals with the same guy
i don't really like him right but i'm
doing business with him
and and this is not a new thing for
anybody anybody that's not doing
business with people they don't want to
do business with is lying
there's somebody you got people that
work for you you don't like our goal was
to get we started with four employees uh
and our goal was to get to 50 employees
and the goal really was not so much to
make a lot of money i wanted i wanted to
me a lot of money in those days was i
want to own a house
i want to have a nice car and i wanted
to
work with interesting people and do
interesting things and i thought if i
could control my own environment have a
small consulting company and oracle
started out as a software consulting
company we work for tandem computer if
anyone remembers those guys we work for
ibm that we worked for a lot of uh
different tech companies in silicon
valley doing contract programming fixed
price contract programming and we did
pretty well
actually and and again the idea was just
to have a small software contract
software company
a
bunch of you know we thought we were hot
shot programmers and we thought we could
make a decent living doing just that and
quite by accident we built a product now
i'm going through and teaching myself
neural networks and you know doing the
same thing with machine learning and
gans and this and that because
ai
is going to have more of an impact than
the internet did ai plus new types of
chipsets plus 5g is going to change
things far more than we've ever seen
anything change
and understanding where and how to apply
it is going to be critical but just as
important knowing how to sep
segregate and separate the
yeah right is as important because every
email you are about to send me
is going to say i have this ai solution
and we're using algorithms
yeah of course you are right and then
what what really makes you different
what really sets you apart but if i
didn't do that work if i didn't sit down
and do the aws machine learning
tutorials if i didn't go on youtube and
take you know the nyu introduction to
neural networks or whatever i'm not
going to know it i'm not going to be
able to apply it and i'm not going to be
able to be first and that's fun that's
fun knowing i get to kick the ass to
some 22 year old nyu graduate that's
awesome is i'm taking my amazon lottery
winnings and i'm converting them
into reusable rocket vehicles
so that we can lower the cost
of access to space because right now the
price of admission to do interesting
things in space is just too high if i
look at what amazon was able to do
20 years ago we didn't have to build a
transportation network it already
existed that heavy lifting was in place
we didn't have to build a payment system
that heavy lifting had already been done
it was the credit card system we didn't
have to build um put a computer at every
desk that had already been done too
mostly for playing games by the way and
so on so all the pieces of heavy lifting
were already in place 20 years ago and
that's why as a with a million dollars i
could start this company
today you know and and then there are
even better examples on the internet
over the last 20 years you know facebook
started in a dorm room
i guarantee you two kids cannot build a
giant space company in their dorm room
it's impossible but i want to create the
heavy lifting infrastructure kind of do
the hard part
so that a future the future generation
two kids in a dorm room will be able to
create a giant space company the hardest
thing for me early on
was you know because i i just started
off as i was
i was an engineer or you know i wasn't
even really an engineer as a student
right it's i i thought i was going to be
an engineer when i graduated
and
you know when you're when you're
building something yourself
you kind of have all the meetings in
your head right it's like you don't need
to articulate the principles so clearly
it's like you kind of can make all the
trade-offs on on everything from
architecture to product to marketing to
you know just all these things and
you're kind of just you have the context
to trade this off and
i think it's really
easy when you start
building something to
to underestimate
how much context you need to put out
there and how clear you need to be about
what you're trying to do so you know
most of my mistakes early on in building
the company
were about not being clear enough
internally about what we were trying to
do and there's this very famous
episode where
we're like
in 2006 a couple years into building the
company
yahoo tried to buy us and so they
offered a ton of money
and
a lot of the people who who i'd hired at
the point they were kind of experienced
technology executives and this was like
all of their startup dream come true
right they joined and then you know
within you know a year or a few months
like the the company had the opportunity
to exit for this large amount of money
and
[Music]
you know i really
failed through that period to
communicate what we were trying to do
and what we what we stood for
and
in the absence of that
that context then of course it was a
rational thing for people to think that
this was like a good outcome for us to
have
foreign
foreign
[ __ ]
everybody works hard
and everybody has their own dreams
there is
there was a time
where i used to spend a lot of energy
wanting things
wanting things
of course it's easy for me to say oh
things don't define you because i got a
lot of things things are nice i like
them
but this is what i learned
when you can surrender to the dream
you get to live in the space of the
higher power
you get to live in the space
that you purposefully have come to earth
to claim for yourself so
around 1984
i was sitting in bed one morning uh
sunday morning should have been in
church but i wouldn't
i was reading
the new york times review of the color
purple
and i thought whoa this sounds like a
really great book i got out of bed in my
pajamas put on my galoshes
and
went to the store to get the copy of the
color purple
i read the color purple in one afternoon
got
went back to the bookstore bought every
book of the color purple i took the
books to the office and i said to
everybody y'all got to read this book oh
my god you got to read this book color
purple i needed a book club i didn't
have one
so i pass out the book to everybody i
knew please read the color purple read
the color purple
then i start to hear
that somebody's going to do a movie
about the color purple but i don't know
anybody in the movie business by this
time i was on am chicago i don't know
anybody i start praying to god god
please help me find a way to get into
color purple
i say jesus i don't even have to have a
speaking part
i will be because i went to the movies
and i saw on the movie credits
at the last credit there's something
called best boy
so i said jesus if you just let me be
best girl
that'll be all right by me i can be best
girl
i can carry the script i can help the
people with the water i can do whatever
so i start praying for the color purple
as
as
divine law would have it quincy jones
comes to chicago
and he is in chicago for one half of a
day
because somebody has filed a suit
against michael jackson claiming that
billie jean was their lover and that's
not his song
so quincy had taken the red eye to
chicago
he was in his hotel room
he was coming out of the shower
and the television in his hotel room is
on am chicago
there sits
little chubby me
with my jerry curl
on am chicago
quincy jones tells ruben cannon the
casting agent i think i found sophia so
i get a call
for movement cannon who says i'm calling
about a movie
it's called moon song would you be
interested to come and audition and i
say i have not been praying for moon
song
[Applause]
[Music]
i had not been playing for moon song
i've been praying for the color purple
he said well
i think you should come and and audition
so i go to audition you know movie
people they make everything all secret
steven spielberg didn't want anybody
know he was doing color purple so on the
outside of the script it says moon song
but i know all the words by heart
so when i open the script i know this is
the color purple jesus this is the color
purple
yes
so i auditioned for the color purple i
can't even believe it they don't just
want me to be the water girl
or the best girl they are asking me do i
want a part in the movie oh that i'm
thinking prayer prayer works
prayer works
[Applause]
but listen to this
three months pass three months is a long
time
i auditioned in february
march
april may comes i haven't heard anything
so i call reuben cannon
i say mr cannon
i'm sorry sir i haven't heard anything i
expected to hear something by now and
reuben cannon
african-american man
says to me
you don't call me
i call you
and i didn't call you
do you understand that i have real
actresses who have auditioned for this
part
real actresses and he tells me who just
left his office and i went well okay i'm
not getting that part
so i hang up the phone and i start
crying
i can't believe that god has played this
trick on me i think
this is a trick
so i decide that this is because the fat
has finally caught up with me
the fat has finally caught up with me
and now i must get rid of the fat
in two weeks
[Applause]
i am going to go to a fat farm
and i'm going to lose
25 pounds
i'm gonna drink a lot of green juice
i'm gonna have some cleanses and
colonics
so i
i i also
was trying to make peace with it
i said god i don't understand
i thought it was for me you ever had
that talk with god
i i thought it was for me i thought it
was for me
god you let me audition with somebody
named harpo
that's my name backwards jesus that was
a sign wasn't it a sign
and then three months pass and then then
reuben cannon says real
actresses have just left his office
so i start to pray on the track i'm out
on the track
at the fat farm
and i am running around at the track
at the fat farm
it starts to rain
y'all know how that is
but i don't even care cause i am praying
to god to help me to let it go
help me let it go because now i've
become obsessed with it and it's now
controlling my life i start praying
running around the track
[Music]
and i keep hearing this noise and i i
can't there's nobody on the track but me
and i'm running around the track
and i look around and it is my thighs
rubbing together
[Applause]
it's my thighs
[Applause]
my thighs
are rubbing together
causing this thunderous sound
[Applause]
there's nobody on the track so then i
really start to cry
oh lord help me
help me let it go help me let it go help
me let it go god help me let it go
and you ever did this prayer where you
say okay lord i'll come and let it go
then you get up and you go well i think
i still got a little bit of it
i did help me let it go
but i am not going to be able to see the
other actress
in my part i won't be able to see it
won't be able to see color purple just
can't never see it the rest of my life i
won't be able to see it
so then i started
i don't know where it came from
i surrender all
i
surrender all
all
to thee my
blessed savior
i
surrender
all
i sang and i cried
i sang and i cried and i prayed some
more
until i could reach the point where not
only
not only will i be able to go to the
movie but i can bless
the other actress
i can bless her
i can say
[Music]
[Applause]
i bless you i bless you i bless you with
this i surrender all i
surrender all
all
to thee
my
blessed savior
i surrender
all
and i tell you
in my greatest testimony
that the instant i laid that thing down
[Applause]
i'm telling you when i laid it down
when i laid it down and it didn't have
me anymore
it had no control over me anymore
i didn't feel anything about it anymore
when i let it go
when i intentionally surrendered it to
the power that was greater than i could
ever know the instant that happened
a woman comes running out of the
cafeteria screaming offering
is your name all free
for 10 years nobody can pronounce my
name
i said yes she said somebody's on the
telephone for you he's a named spielberg
i get to the phone
he says i hear you're at a fat farm
i said no sir
this is a health retreat
[Music]
he says i'd like to see you in my office
in california tomorrow this was in
wisconsin i was i'd like to see you in
my office
and if you lose a pound
you could lose this part
no
problem do i have
i'll have no problem not losing a pound
so honey i packed my bags
and i stopped at the dairy queen
[Applause]
i got three scoops just in case i'd lost
a half a pound
[Applause]
and the next day i was in steven
spielberg's office and he said you're
hired you're hired in the early days i
mean as an entrepreneur you're every
department so
i was the before and after butt model
literally i took a picture of my own
butt took it to kinko's got it laminated
with and without spanx on stood in the
stores and i'm like hey look what this
can do for you um i was i was like the
packer and shipper i was the head of
sales i was everything and you learn
very quickly what you're good at and
what you're not good at and what you
enjoy and what you don't enjoy and
there's usually a correlation between
the two and so i often say as soon as
you can afford to hire your weaknesses
and a few years into spanx um it was
abundantly clear that the lane that i
needed to stay in was inventing selling
promoting spanx actually is never
advertised spanx is 18 years old and the
first time we've ever even sampled an ad
was to uh in 16. and so i was
sort of the the advertisement and and me
being out in the field talking about the
product and sharing the story of the why
why we're making this why it's better
was a big part of the formula and i
needed someone to be in the company
day-to-day running the daily operations
success is a contact sport
you cannot be successful if you don't
make contact
you guys interview people and then you
never follow anybody up man nobody
follows anybody up
i spent i spent two million dollars with
a lawyer that's never called me back
same thing for the barber same thing for
the cosmetologist same thing for the
plumber same thing for the roofer dude
you guys don't call people back because
you think they're not interested do you
think i'm only going to have one car
accident people that have one car
accident end up in three of them
okay divorcees god gets a divorce
everybody here knows somebody's got four
of them
but he ends up with four different
attorneys
like you guys don't follow up you are a
business not a lawyer
the chiropractor has the same problem he
goes and spends all this money on
equipment he knows how to do an
adjustment he doesn't know how to build
a business well i was lucky that i got
started early i mean always helps if you
get started early and
and my dad happened to be in investment
business so i would go down his office
on
saturdays and so at age probably seven
or something i started reading these
books that were around the place and
so i had a
15-year jump on many people in in a
sense and that that helped a lot and and
i was always fascinated by them i knew
what i wanted to do early and i think
that's a that's a huge advantage too
and then
you don't need you don't need a lot of
brains in this business i mean i've
always said if you got an iq of 160 give
away 30 points to somebody else because
you don't need it in investments what
you do need is emotional stability you
have to
you have to be able to think
independently and you have to be you
have to be
when you come to a conclusion you have
to really not care what other people say
and and just follow the facts and follow
your reasoning and and that's that's
tough for a lot of people but
that part i think i was just lucky with
i was born that way
in terms of emotions that uh truism that
investing emotions are your enemy
absolutely that uh when the market's
good if you feel good don't if you feel
bad you should probably do it right
but uh how uh how how did you uh what
was that extra thing where uh so many
will acknowledge that and yet we saw in
the current crisis they they panicked
why you went into seemingly uh potential
disasters like ge and goldman sachs
i i can't really tell you the i mean i
didn't learn in school or anything i
just it never bothered me if people
disagreed with what i thought
as long as i felt i knew the facts i
mean there's a whole bunch of things i
don't know think about i just stay away
from those so i stay within what i call
my circle of confidence you know that
tom watson said it best he said you know
he said he said i'm no genius but i'm
smart in spots and i stay around those
spots well i try and stay around those
spots and i
i just don't have a problem if if
if somebody says you know you're wrong
on something i just i go back and look
at the facts and and
i think that
i think that really is much more
important frankly than than having a few
points of iq or or having an extra
course or two in in school or anything
of the sort you need emotional stability
[Music]
if you want seven more amazing lessons
from billionaires check out the video
right there next to me i think you'll
love it continue to believe and i'll see
you there you should just be yourself
right i mean i take pride in the fact
that i didn't give what anybody thought
or said i was just going to be myself i
find if i don't get enough sleep then
i'm i'm quite grumpy
i mean obviously